i I just had the best joke about Vonda
marijuana I was having lunch with him
just a few minutes ago and the Nigerian
journalist comes and this will only
makes sense if you ever watched a James
Bond movie and a journalist comes up to
him and goes AHA we meet again Mr Bond
that's great so I've got a little sheet
of paper here mostly because I'm
Nigerian and if you if you leave me
alone I'll talk for like two hours but
I'm I just want to say good good
afternoon good evening it's been an
incredible few days it's downhill from
now on I wanted to thank your maker and
Chris but also most importantly all the
invisible people behind Ted that you
just see flitting around the whole place
that have made the sort of this this
space for such a diverse and robust
conversation that's really amazing now
being in the audience I'm a writer and
I've been watching people with
slideshows and scientists and bankers
and I've been feeling a bit like a
gangster rapper at a Bar Mitzvah
I think what have I got to say about all
this and I was watching Jo Jane
yesterday and I thought it was really
great names I was watching those
incredible slides although of the
chimpanzees and I thought wow what if a
chimpanzee could talk no what would it
say my first thought was well you know
there's George Bush but then I thought
why be rude to chimpanzees so I'm I
guess there goes my green card there's
been a lot of talk about narrative in
Africa and what's become increasingly
clear to me is that we're talking about
news stories about Africa we're not
really talking about Africa narratives
and then it's important to make a
distinction because if if the news is
anything to go by 40% of Americans can't
either either can't afford health
insurance or have the most inadequate
health insurance have a president who
despite the the protests of millions of
his citizens even his own Congress
continues to prosecute a senseless war
so if news is anything to go by and the
u.s. is right there with Zimbabwe right
which which it isn't really is there and
talking about war my girlfriend has this
great t-shirt that says bombing for
peace is like for virginity
the truth is Americans everything we
know about American everything Americans
come to know about being American isn't
from the news it we live there we don't
go home at the end of the damn thing
well I really know who I am now because
the The Wall Street Journal says that
the stock exchange closed up this many
points what we know about how to be who
we are comes from stories it comes from
the novels the movies the fashion
magazines it comes from popular culture
in other words it's the agents of our
imagination who really shaped who we are
and this is important to remember
because you know in Africa the
complicated questions we want to ask
about what all of this means has been
asked from the rock paintings of the
sand people through the Sundiata epics
of Mali to modern contemporary
literature if you want to know about
Africa read our literature and not just
things fall apart yes that would be like
saying I've read Gone with the Wind and
so I know everything about America it's
very important
here's a poem by Jack Gilbert called The
Forgotten dialect of the heart he says
when the Sumerian tablets were first
translated they were thought to be
business records but what if they were
poems and Psalms my love is like twelve
Ethiopian goats standing still in the
morning light shiploads of fuya or what
my body wants to say to your body
giraffes this desire in the dark this is
important it's important because miss
reading is really the chance for
complication and opportunity
the first ebo Bible was translated from
English and by the 1800s by Bishop
Crowder who was a yerba it's important
to note e bow is a tonal language and so
they say the word eat way and eat way
same spelling one means sky or heaven
and one means bicycle or iron so God is
in heaven surrounded by his angels was
translated as
soup anon a liquid in one cell by a blue
blue and for some reason in Cameroon
when they try to translate the the Bible
into Cameroonian patois they chose the
Ebro version and I'm not going to give
you the part for translation gonna make
you standard English basically
the ends up as God is on a bicycle with
his angels this is good because language
complicates things
you know we often think that language
mirrors the world in which we live and I
find that's not true the language
actually makes the world in which we
live language is not I mean things don't
have any mutable value by themselves we
ascribe them a value and language can't
be understood in its abstraction it can
only be understood in the context of
story and everything everything all of
this is story and it's important to
remember that because if we don't then
we become a historical we've had a lot
of a period of amazing ideas here but
these are not new to Africa Nigeria got
its independence in 1960 the first time
the possibility for independence was
discussed was in 1922 following the
abandoned women's market riots in 1967
in the middle of the Biafra Nigerian
civil war dr. Andrew Kobe invented the
cholera vaccine so you know the thing is
to remember that because otherwise ten
years from now we'll be back here trying
to tell the story again so what it says
to me then is that it's not really the
problem isn't really the stories that
are being told or which stories have
been told the problem really is the
terms of humanity that we're willing to
bring to complicate every story and
that's really what it's all about until
your Nigerian joke well it's just a joke
anyway so there's Tom Dick and Harry and
they're working construction and Tom
opens up his lunch box and there's rice
in it and he goes on this rant about
twenty years my wife has been packing
rice for lunch if she does it again
tomorrow and throw myself off this
building and kill myself
and they can Harry repeat this the next
day Tom opens his lunch boxes right so
he throws himself off and kills himself
and Tom Dick and Harry
and at the inquest you know Tom's wife
and Diggs wife were distraught they wish
they did not packed rice but Harry's
wife is confused because she said you
know had been packing his own lunch for
20 years
it's similarly innocent joke when I
heard it as a child in Nigeria was told
about Ebola Robin Hauser with the houses
are being hairy so what seems like a an
eccentric of tragic joke about Harry
becomes a way to spread ethnic hatred
my father was educated in Cork
University of cork and the 50s in fact
every time I read in Ireland people get
me all mistaken and they say oh this is
crystal Barney from Cork but it was also
in Oxford in the 50s and yet growing up
as a child in Nigeria my father used to
say to me you must never eat or drink in
a Europa person's house because they
will poison you it makes sense now when
I think about it because if you'd known
my father you would have wanted to
poison him too
so I was born in 1966 at the beginning
of the Biafra Nigerian civil war and the
war ended after three years and I was
growing up in school and the federal
government didn't want us taught about
the history the history of the war
because and they thought it probably
would make us generate a new generation
of rebels so I had a very inventive
teacher Pakistani Muslim who wanted to
teach us about this so what he did was
to teach us a Jewish Holocaust history
so how did run books with photographs of
people in ostrich
I learned the melancholic history of my
people through the melancholic history
of another people I mean picture this
really picture this a Pakistani Muslim
teaching Jewish Holocaust history too
young I bore children stories powerful
stories fluid and it belongs to nobody
and it should come as no surprise in
that my first novel at 16 was about
neo-nazis taking over Nigeria to
institute the Fourth Reich
makes perfect sense and there were two
blow-up strategic targets and take over
the country and they were foiled by a
Nigerian James Bond called coyote
Williams and Jewish a Jewish Nazi hunter
and it happened over four continents and
when the book came out I was heralded as
Africa's answer to Frederick Forsyth
which is a dubious honor best but
obviously the book was launched in time
for me to be accused of constructing the
blueprint for Foyle to attempt so at 18
I was bonded after prison in Nigeria I
grew up very privileged and it's
important to talk about privilege
because we don't talk about it here a
lot of us are very privileged I grew up
servants cars televisions all that stuff
my story of Nigeria growing up was very
different from the story encountered in
prison and I had no language for it it
was completely terrified completely
broken and kept trying to find a new
language a new way to make sense of all
of this six months after that with no
explanation they let me go now those of
you who've seen here the buffer tables
and all that it was because it was
costing them too much to feed me
[Applause]
but I mean I grew up with this
incredible privilege and not just me and
millions of Nigerians grew up with books
in libraries in fact we were talking
last night about how all of the the
steamy novels of Howard Robbins had done
more for sex education of horny teenage
boys in Africa than any sex education
program has ever had all of those are
gone we are squandering the most
valuable resource we have on this
continent the valuable resource of the
imagination in the film sometimes in
April bara will Peck Idris Alba it's
poison the scene with his machete raised
and he's been forced by a crowd to chop
up his best friend fellow Rwandan army
officer Albie the Tutsi played by Fraser
James and phrases on his knees arms tied
behind his back and he's crying he's
sniveling it's a pitiful sight and as we
watch it we are ashamed and we want to
say to Idris chop him up shut him up
and that is idrees moves fraser screams
stop please stop
adrià spices then he moves again and
Fraser says please please stop and it's
not the look of horror and terror on
fraises face that stops a dress or us
it's the look in phrases eyes it's one
that says don't do this and I'm not
saying this to save myself although this
would be nice I'm doing it to save you
because if you do this you will be lost
to be so afraid and you're standing in
the face of a death you can't escape and
that you're soiling yourself and crying
but to say in that moment and Fraser
says the Idris tell my girlfriend I love
her in that moment it just says Fraser
says I am lost already but not you not
you this is a Redemption we can all
aspire to
African narratives in the West they
prefer aid I really don't care anymore
more interested in the stories we tell
about ourselves how as a writer I find
that African writers have always been
the curators of our humanity on this
continent the question is how do i
balance narratives that are wonderful
with narratives of wounds and
self-loathing and this is the difficulty
that I face I'm trying to move beyond
political rhetoric to a place of ethical
questioning i'm asking us to balance the
idea of our complete vulnerability with
the complete notion of transformation of
what is possible the young middle class
and I join activist I launched myself
along with a whole generation of us into
the campaign to to stop the government
and I asked millions of people without
questioning my right to do so to go up
against the devil is and I watched him
being locked up in prison in tear gassed
I justified it and I said this is the
cost of revolution have I not myself
been imprisoned have I not myself being
beaten it wasn't until later when I was
imprisoned again that I understood the
real meaning of torture and how easy
your humanity can be taken from you for
the time I was engaged in war righteous
righteous war excuse me
sometimes I can stand before the world
I'm gonna say this transformation is a
difficult and slow process sometimes I
can stand before the world and say my
name is Chris Abani I've been human six
days but only sometimes but this is a
good thing it's never gonna be easy
there are no answers as I stop telling
Rachel from Google Earth that I
challenged my students in America said
you don't know anything about Africa
you're all idiots and so they said tell
me about Africa professor Barney so I
went to Google Earth and learned about
Africa and the truth be told this is it
isn't it there are no essential Africa's
and most of us are completely ignorant
as everyone else about the continent we
come from and yet we want to make
profound statements about it and I think
if we can just admit that we're all
trying to approximate the truth of our
own communities
it will make for much more nuanced and a
much more interesting conversation I
want to believe that we can be agnostic
about this that we can rise above all of
this when I was 10 I read James
Baldwin's another country and that book
broke me
not because I was encountering
homosexual sex and love for the first
time but because the way James wrote
about it made it impossible for me to
attach other Ness to it here Jimmy said
here is love all of it the fact that it
happens in another country takes you by
surprise my friend one of goddess Minh
says there are three kinds of people in
the world those who can count and those
who can't he also says that the cause of
all our trouble is the belief in an
essential pure identity religious ethnic
historical ideological I want to leave
you with a poem by Yusef Komunyakaa that
speaks to transformation is called ode
to the drum and I'll try and read it the
way Yusef would be proud to hear it read
gazelle I killed you for your skin's
exquisite touch for how easy it is to be
nailed to a board where the draw as
white butcher paper last night I heard
my daughter praying for the meat here at
my feet you know it was an anger that
made me stop my heart till the hammer
fell weeks ago you broke me as a woman
once shattered me into a song beneath
her wait before you slouched into that
grassy hush and now I'm tightening
lashes shaven hide as if around the rib
cage shaped like five bow strings ghosts
cannot slip back inside the bodies drama
you've been seasoned by when the dust
and sunlight pressure can make
everything whole again brass nails
tacked into the ebony wood your face is
being carved five times I have to drive
trouble in the hills trouble in the
valley and travel by the river - there
is no palm wine
salt or calabash padam padam the
doom-doom
now I have beaten a song back into you
rise and walk away like a panther thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]